[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la crainte qui te sauveras j'ai
commencé à bosser je m'occupais
d'enfants dans un centre de loisirs
particulièrement les petits les 3 6 ans
je crois que je n'oublierai jamais les
mots de ma chef mon premier jour tu sais
marion les enfants n'y a pas besoin de
les punir
non non ce qu'il faut c'est qu'ils aient
la crainte de ils savent pas de quoi ils
savent pas ce que tu vas faire mais ils
savent que tu pourrais éventuellement
faire quelque chose si tu veux qu'ils te
bénisse c'est la crainte qui te sauveras
j'avais 17 ans j'avais 17 ans et voilà
comment on m'a présenté le truc deux ans
plus tard
deux ans plus tard je pars en suède en
tant que fille au pair dans une famille
de trois enfants
je suis arrivé depuis à peu près une
semaine et le plus petit jeu c'est même
plus un vraiment ce qu'ils veulent enfin
en tout cas ils n'écoutaient pas
vraiment et moi je me sentais un peu
perdu dans tout ça alors je le mitraille
avec mes yeux noirs attention hein je
vais me lever
j'essaye d'y mettre tout le sérieux du
monde comme on l'a appris en fait hélas
le petit bonhomme quatre ans il se
retourne il me regarda son tour avec un
regard carrément intrigué puis me dis
comme ça avec tout le naturel du monde
par les flots
la suède la suède c'est le premier pays
du monde à avoir aboli les châtiments
corporels et les humiliations faites aux
enfants et c'était il ya plus de 40 ans
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que là bas la crainte elle ne
sonnera pas un jour un jour je discutais
avec une enseignante suédoise
et puis dans la conversation dans la
conversation je lui parle des enfants
rois
parce que j'avais envie d'en savoir un
petit peu plus quand même sur leur
vision du concept les enfants les 101
les enfants rois ah oui mais tu veux
parler de victoria notre princesse qui
est enceinte mais tu t'intéresses à
l'avenue mont-royal toi marion
au début je vous le dis sincèrement j'ai
cru que le foot et noir puis en fait
j'ai compris j'ai compris qu'elle voyait
vraiment pas de quoi je parlais les
enfants ses petits rois qui nous
écoutent pas acquis qu'ils nous
respectent pas qu'ils veulent décider
tout vous êtes jamais dit vouloir que
les enfants mais il écoute décidément
jamais rien mais ce qu'on les écoute
est ce qu'on les respecte nous leurs
modèles mais le prend pas dans tes bras
à la fin tu vas en faire un capricieux
montre lui qui décide c'est quand même
pas les mômes qui vont faire la loi
non mais attends si tu le laisses faire
là tu vas te faire bouffer qui d'entre
vous n'a jamais entendu ces phrases
c'est à se demander dès fois ci on
devient parent ou si on adopte en fait
une sorte de spécimens génétiquement
modifiés qui serait du genre croisé en
train dangereux pitbull a eu un
abominable boad 2 mètres 50
allez c'est bon là on n'avait vu venir
ça va encore nous parler de l'éducation
bienveillante la nouvelle tendance là
aujourd'hui en france respecter ses
enfants sa porte un nom l'éducation
bienveillante
on peut pas parler d'éducation tout
court non parce que ne pas utiliser
toutes ces violences qu'on dit ordinaire
des violences éducatives ordinaires
bah c'est bel et bien être dans de
l'alternatif dû faire autrement c'est un
peu comme si chez nous faire normalement
c'est être vexant cassant violent vous
connaissez pas vous la nouvelle méthode
de vie de couple bienveillante
ah si si je vous assure paraît que c'est
pareil que c'est super à la mode
non mais enfin marion marion tu lis
c'est la violence sur les enfants
c'est un peu la racine de toutes les
autres violences de notre monde de la
délinquance de la criminalité tout ça
mais vous en france c'est un truc que
vous ignorez tout vous pensez même que
celle inverse punissons vexo voir ta
pour les enfants et ça en fera des gens
bien ça c'était une amie suédoise qui me
l'avait sorti un jour puis elle avait
ajouté à chaque mot dur à chaque main
levée on perd notre humanité
parce que ça fait disparaître ce qui
nous rend justement humain
un monde moins violent un monde un monde
plus empathique un monde plus à l écoute
on en rêve tous un peu quand même non
ouais mais les enfants il faut bien les
éduquer comment on fait là si on peut
plus les punir ça va venir des enfants
fins et puis quand même c'est pour leur
bien un an
c'est pourtant bien si je te punit là
c'est pour ton bien si je suis dur comme
ça avec toi tu sais c'est pour ton bien
cette gifle là c'est pour ton bien cette
petite phrase c'est le titre d'un
bouquin qui est venu dénoncer la
pédagogie noire
alice miller a été la première à nommer
mais aussi à parler en fait de l'impact
des violences faites aux enfants non de
l'éducation de leurs conséquences sur
les individus et de leurs conséquences
sur toute la société en fait sur notre
monde
elle est décédée il ya dix ans
maintenant mais c'est écrit eux ils
n'ont pas pris une ride quoi
on humilie jamais un enfant pour son
bien on l'humilie uniquement parce que
nous même enfant en a été humiliée et
qu'on a refoulé combien on a souffert
vous avez tous je pense un jour ici dans
la salle reçu une punition
j'aimerais bien d'ailleurs là si vous le
voulez bien que tous vous repensez à une
punition qui vous a marqué dans votre
enfance
ça peut être n'importe quoi essayez de
vous reconnecter c'est de vous remettre
à la place de cet enfant que vous étiez
200 enfants qui étaient punis je vous
laisse faire ça tranquillement
d'un coup là dans cette salle dans cette
salle il ya plus que des enfants des
enfants pris en faute des enfants punis
bah vous quoi comment vous vous sentez
là ce que vous pouvez me donner quelques
quelques mots de votre ressenti vos
impressions qu'est ce qui vous vient
comment vous vous sentez de la honte
were de l' angoisse la tristesse
incompréhension colère de l'injustice de
l'énergie basse voix je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez mais alors franchement
l'ambiance avec louvre de là dans la
salle quand même depuis que tout cela
vous êtes redevenu des enfants les
enfants qui se trouvent nulle des
enfants qui se trouve méchant
vous me parlez de colère avant de parler
d'injustice vous me parler d'énergie
basse mais comme je vous comprends enfin
mais par dit tout ce que vous semblez
ressentir parmi tous ces ressentis qui
sont remis à vous il me manque un
élément fondamental il ya personne ici
là qui m'a parlé d'un ressenti de de
remords l' envie de mieux faire envie de
réparer après cette punition
nous les êtres humains à la naissance on
a un super pouvoir tous on a tous super
pouvoirs et ce super pouvoirs c'est la
loyauté quand moi je viens au monde
j'ai besoin de toi papa besoin de toi
maman pour tout être changée être nourri
est de protéger sans toi je meurs et ça
mon organisme il le sait très bien
tu te sers le doigts très fort ne me
lâche pas ste place je connais pas ce
monde
puis quand je vais devenir jeune enfant
petit à petit quand je me rends compte
qu'en fait toi l'adulte sens et
m'apporter tout la protection à tu peux
aussi me faire du mal à cette découverte
c'est un séisme dans ma vie toi mon
pilier censé me protéger tu peux aussi
crié tu peux taper tu peux m'humilier
mais alors moi je suis en danger
toi mon gage de survie dans cette jungle
complètement inconnue tue seraient en
fait des saillant mais alors moi je peux
mourir bien trop petit pour savoir quoi
faire
cette vérité qui remet toute mon
existence en jeu je vais m'accuser si tu
me punit si tu cries si tu me lis c'est
une tape c'est parce que je suis méchant
je suis mauvais tu as raison de me
corriger c'est moi c'est ma faute
tu peux pas être défaillant c'est tout
ce que j'ai
alors bien sûr bien sûr nombreux
nombreux sont les gens suis pas mort
ouais ce réflexe ce réflexe de
protection du parent référent
cette volonté de protéger le parent
référent sa réflexe qui est ancré en
nous il est animal le petit enfant il
peut pas faire autrement mais l'adulte
oui on peut tous aller à la recherche de
cette souffrance enfouie de ce qui est
en fait à l'origine une terreur la
terreur de mourir tout enfant même le
plus maltraité a littéralement besoin à
viscéralement besoin de cette allusion
d'être aimée inconditionnellement
mais les adultes peuvent abandonner
cette illusion s'ils veulent pas le
payer d'une dépression
mais alors pourquoi pourquoi on
reproduit sur nos enfants sur la
prunelle de nos yeux ce qui nous a tant
fait souffrir quand nous mêmes on était
enfant je t'aime pas maman va vous dire
votre enfant larmes
et là vous vous retenez mais vous vous
retenez pour pas explo d'un moi non plus
je t'aime pas cuite est pas belle quand
tu pleures vous le disiez vous même vous
ressentiez de la tristesse de la colère
de l'injustice de la haine quand vous
étiez rabaisser enfants bat croyez pas
que ces sentiments sont partis qui se
sont volatilisés non ils sont juste
endormi
ils sont tapis bien au fond de vous et
aujourd'hui face à l'enfant en face de
vous l'enfant en vous en découdre parce
que c'est plus facile
c'est beaucoup plus facile de s'attaquer
aux enfants qui de toute façon nous vous
une loyauté sans borne
c'est beaucoup plus facile plutôt que
d'aller voir la véritable origine de
cette colère de cette violence en nous
c'est pas le fait que l'enfant en face
de nous pleurs qui nous met en rage
on ressent cette rage uniquement parce
que cet enfant là ils versent les larmes
du nous on n'a jamais eu le droit de
verser à son âge
je reviens à 2012
c'est une histoire un peu longue je vais
vous la faire très courte
j'avais expliqué à mes petits suédois
qu'en france on était quand même un
certain nombre à combattre pour une loi
une loi pour les enfants contre les
violences une loi comme chez eux
il se passe un temps j'ai dit que vous
l'aviez courtin et puis l'un d'eux
revient de voir marion j'ai réfléchi à
ce que tu as dit que tu as dis là tout à
l'heure quand même que les adultes des
fois dans ton pays tap les enfants quand
ils font des bêtises
j'ai réfléchi ça m'a travaillé je crois
que j'ai trouvé une solution
en fait c'est pas très compliqué les
enfants là qui sont happés par les
adultes ils ont qu'à le dire à leurs
parents
ouais d'accord
bah ouais mais comment pourrait-il en
être autrement en fait dans sa tête de
petit suédois qui a jamais subi mais qui
a même en fait jamais vu un truc pareil
avec ma caméra justement je suis allé
dans les rues de stockholm
vous rencontrez un peu les gens je les
appelle la génération imbattable je vous
laisse découvrir un petit peu pour
témoignage
photo bernard bonnel
mes chers enfants ce que vous savez la
super nouvelle eh ben c'est que la
france en juillet 2019 ça y est enfin
la france est devenue le 56e pays du
monde à abolir ce qu'on appelait le
droit de correction
quatre décennies après le la cette loi
cette fois c'est un cadeau pour les
futurs parents vos enfants seront un
jour enfin leur offre ça à nos enfants
ont leur offs est si magnifique
ignorance des mécanismes de la violence
sur les gens qu'on aime
l'autorité parentale s'exerce sans
violence physique ou psychologique avant
cette loi soit votée
87% de parents le parent français disait
donner des fessées 71% des gifles et la
moitié de ces gens avant que l'enfant né
deux ans
87% et est-ce qu'on est bien devenu
adulte en fait finalement est ce que ces
traitements nous ont pas justement
dangereusement freiner dans notre
développement dans notre bon sens quoi
87%
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle
on sait ce que nos ancêtres ne savait
pas on a toutes les preuves maintenant
de la nocivité des cris des coups des
punitions des humiliations
mais entre être inspiré et être
paralysée par toutes ces nouvelles
connaissances à la frontière avait quand
même très fine ans il nous faut
maintenant tous ensemble collectivement
réapprendre ce qui était innée chez nous
prendre soin de nos enfants vraiment en
prendre soin c'est d'abord ça
l'étymologie la définition du mot
éducation prendre soin et la définition
des violences éducatives ordinaires
alors ça serait quoi
et bah ça serait peut-être juste une
construction purement social basé sur
nos propres souffrances d'enfants jamais
entendu jamais reconnu
quand je serai grand moi je ferais pas
ça à mes enfants je leur ferai jamais ça
mes enfants jamais moi je ferais pas
comme ça avec mes enfants vous souvenez
ben ça y est ça y est les amis on est
grand vous imaginez un peu notre france
dans quelques années quand un parent
lèvera la main au dessus de la tête de
son enfant ça claquera bien fort et
sakhr ira encore plus fort tope là on a
gagné et ce jour là ouais ce jour là je
pense qu'on aurait gagné
merci
[Applaudissements]